setting for game three another picture
perfect night for baseball in san diego
california we are at petco park and this
series is all tied at one game a piece
excellent pitching matchup for game
three the yankees in pinstripes tonight
they are the home team in this neutral
sight setting it's the 2020 american
league division series tanaka ronnie 31
years of age coming to the end of a
contract with the yankees he's been
excellent in his career if you see the
bottom postseason career era 2.70 it was
1.75 until his last start in cleveland
where he gave up 6-1 78 and 46 over his
brilliant career over 173 starts with
the yankees austin meadows digs in
doesn't pack that big power fastball
that we've seen he gets a strikeout to
start the game
meadows chases
and that's how the night begins
for tanaka tanaka facing brandon lau
as we are just underway and tanaka with
back-to-back strikeouts to start his day
and a rosarena flying down the line as a
board extends the inning for g-man choi
and choi on the first pitch hammers one
into right field that's well hit and it
is going to be caught by judge how about
that a snow cone
staring back into the sun you want to
talk about a great play
wow charlie morton his second year as a
tampa bay ray
living in the area decided to extend his
career after he contemplated retirement
after his days with the houston astros
we'll have it right here on tbs
popped him up in the infield
nine first inning for
both starting pitchers ten pitch first
inning for charlie morton retires the
side in order off and running in game
three kevin kiermeier now with two on
and one away ready for a 2-2
and a wave animus tanaka had him fooled
kiermeier strikes out for out number two
of this second inning two men are gone
still two men on and now the catcher
michael perez there they go and a swing
and a liner that is over the glove of le
mayhew into right field in the score is
wendell
on his way to third and in there easily
as adamus it's an rbi single for michael
perez
and the ray strike first here in game
three tadaka's got him in an o2 count
and he strikes him out to end the ending
so the ray strand a pair but they score
first
john carlos stanton coming to the plate
and down he goes charlie morton with a
strikeout five in a row retired that's
his first k he's got a great curveball
one of the best breaking balls in the
game still and he powers up torres right
there strikes him out facing glaber
torres to start this third
and a wave at a miss struck him out on
three consecutive pitches got him with a
breaking ball that time strikeout number
four for morton
and le mayhew draws the walk now they
are loaded
so the first real trouble of the night
for charlie morton faces loaded with
judge coming up
a judge
in the air shallow right
that's gonna be meadow he's got a strong
arm gardner tags here comes the throw
and it's late and the yankees are on the
board aaron judge with a sacrifice
flight at rbi
we are tied at one
big pitch coming right here from morton
two men are out and hicks draws the walk
another patient at that by aaron hicks
once again they are loaded for
the yankees 3-2 pitch runners go and
it's beat right into the ground adamus
will wind it up and that will retire the
side that's a big out for charlie morton
in the rays the yankees in trouble here
tampa bay threatening with two on kevin
kiermeier at the plate
takes a rip and sends one way back into
right field judge is on the run he's at
the wall and she's gone
kevin kiermeier
put some launch angle on that one
a three-run home run
and the raise up 4-1
damage from the bottom of the batting
order once again for tampa bay
brett gardner singled off morton back to
the curve he goes and he got him
down goes gardner a strikeout for
charlie morton
here we go to the fifth inning game
three randy arose arena on the first
pitch sends it deep in the left and
there goes another one for a rosarena
unstoppable right now randy a arena
three more hits tonight he is homered in
each of the first three games of this
division series and the razer of five to
one that brings up aaron judge but still
has that power sinker
and there's a swing of the miss he's got
that one too the power curve
strikes out judge
that strikeout number six out number two
of this fifth inning and now with the
runner at first and two bit out here is
aaron hicks that is a huge break picks
down the right field line
and on the run can't run it down in
right field meadows
la may he was running on the crack of
the bat he'll come all the way around
the score and it's an rbi double for
aaron hicks michael perez at the plate
and he's swinging away and he hammers
one into left field way back gardner is
on the run that ball is going to fly out
of here
michael perez with a two-run blast on an
02 pitch perez launches one out of here
three runs batted in for the game for
him
and it's 7-2 tampa bay desperation time
for the yankees
down the right field line
choi he's gonna one hop one off the
fence with two out to rose arena all the
way around the score
and the rays continue to add on it's now
eight to two so avoided second here is
giancarlo stanton with 112.6
it's a fly ball into center field
here meyer at the wall and he's done it
again
john carlos stand in the two-run home
run yankees down to their last out here
in the ninth inning
the others are fresh and ready for
tomorrow there's a bouncer window gloves
it throws it and that's the ball game
the tampa bay rays now lead 2-1 in this
best of five series